it's fight night at the White House
President Trump Joe Biden going mano y
mano + Mark Zuckerberg this week just
got worse and Republicans struggled to
pass their big omnibus spending bill
will go through all of this stuff and an
exclusive interview with Speaker of the
House Paul Ryan I'm Ben Shapiro this is
Ben Shapiro show
so indeed yesterday we were in
Washington DC we had a great time we got
to go to see all of the sights from the
inside we got to meet with speaker Ryan
will have our exclusive interview with
speaker Ryan a little bit later in the
program so which I'm very much looking
forward to showing you because it was it
was a lot of fun we didn't talk a lot
actually about kind of day-to-day
politics we talked more about broad
things that he should be doing in
Congress to change the nature of
government which i think is a little
more important because we talked to a
today pahala fix it on the show we'll
get to all of that plus the greatest
story of the last two years maybe maybe
it's pretty great
we'll get to that and just one second
first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at my Patriot supply so
right now does it feel like the world
may be about to end well it might be you
know maybe there's a natural disaster
coming your way or maybe there's going
to be a North Korean sneak nuclear
attack probably the natural disasters
more likely in either case you need to
protect your family with an emergency
food supply and you can do it with the
experts at my Patriot supply this is the
week to build a foundation of safety
today you can get this ben shapiro
special offer from my Patriot supply by
one four week emergency food kit for
only a hundred and ninety eight dollars
and you get one free so Buy It Again a
four week emergency food kit for a
hundred ninety eight bucks and you get
one free these kids normally sell for
two hundred seventeen dollars so you're
getting it for about twenty dollars off
you purchase one right now at the low
sale price of one hundred ninety eight
bucks and my Patriot supply sends you an
additional four week food kit for free
so you're getting it for less than half
the price essentially call 888 803 14 13
or order online at prepare with Ben's
calm that's eight eight eight eight oh
three fourteen thirteen or prepare with
Ben calm the kits include breakfast
lunches dinners packed in a rugged
slimline tote this ensures that your
family is safe you buy it you leave it
in the closet you don't have to worry
about it it lasts in storage for twenty
five years and something goes wrong
you're the only one who's prepared go to
prepare with Ben calm there is a
purchase limit of two per order supplies
are limited do it now and we're not
gonna be talking about this amazing
offer anytime again in the air future so
check it out right now prepare with Ben
calm and again get that kit for two
hundred for one hundred ninety eight
bucks and an additional four week food
kit for free when you go to prepare with
Ben dot-com that's prepared with Ben's I
can't make sure that you and your family
are indeed prepared in case of disaster
okay so there is a lot of actual news to
talk about but the most important news
the thing that we all care about the
most is that there's going to be a fight
fight fight fight fight between Joe
Biden the vice president's of the United
States in this corner and
this quarter Donald J macfay strum it's
gonna be so great okay so here's how it
all started so Biden has been trying to
out man from okay Biden understand
something a lot of other politicians
don't you can't actually just fly over
the top of Trump you can't say I'll play
the highroad and he'll play the low road
and we'll be in Scotland before you can
can't actually do that with Trump you
actually have to get down in the mud
with him so Biden gets this and so Biden
speaks Trump's language so there's sort
of weird reverse mirror images of one
another it's like bizarro Trump is Joe
Biden and bizarro Biden is Trump so it's
it's very weird so it starts off clip 13
Joe Biden yesterday saying that he would
have beaten up Trump in high school
which is a real weird thing to say beat
the hell out of the president of United
States says and then he continues this
way so Trump is a fat ugly sob and the
only people who talk like that are the
biggest fattest ugliest sops in the room
funny because you're talking like that
now right now senator Biden and so just
and the or Vice President bite and then
Trump fires back so here's what Trump
tweets just come on this is great stuff
this is a great stuff go out how can you
not love this okay here's anybody trace
back this morning it's so it's so
phenomenal crazy Joe Biden is trying to
act like a tough guy actually he is weak
both mentally and physically and yet he
threatens me for the second time with
physical assault he doesn't know me but
he would go down fast and hard crying
all the way
don't threaten people Joe ok so Joe
Biden had threatened to beat Trump up
actually several months ago saying that
if they got in a fight he would take
down Trump and now you got the President
of the United States imagine this
there's a very funny Twitter account
that takes all of Trump's tweets and
puts them in the format of presidential
statements imagine the presidential
statement like you wake up from a coma
and this is what you see and you're like
Oh Donald Trump is in a fight with wait
don't force the president you treated
that so yeah that's the thing that
and I love it I gotta say I love it
right he's weak both mentally and
physically and yet he threatens me for
the second time with physical assault he
doesn't know me he would go down fast
and hard crying all the way love it fast
and hard crying oh boy
yes and actually so so they're now
booking a fight and the fight will be
booked and we actually have some
training footage of what's been going on
in the run-up to this massive fight I do
a million of these a day so just give me
[Music]
[Applause]
oh man that's hilarious that's Joe Biden
pumping iron the guys on the phone he's
got like a dumbbell he's pumping iron
then it's Trump from WWE just knocking
people over oh it's so great so I have
volunteered if they do this fight first
of all there's no way this is bad for
America
okay America's already toast when it
comes to our vulgar political culture
we're done okay Donald Trump is the
president Hillary ran Joe Biden is an
idiot he's gonna run a meme a win in
2020 oh my goodness okay so I've Ahlan
tear okay I volunteer I won't I won't
get paid for it
I wanna be the announcer on this okay I
wanna be announcer on this I tweeted out
some of the things that I thought would
happen some people tweeted back some
lines so not all of these lines that
we're about to hear on my own but I do
want to announce this fight I think it
would say on something like this
something like this welcome ladies and
gentlemen to the ruckus in the hospice
the brawl on Geritol the melee over the
jello tray the headlock on Matlock this
is a 12-round bout between 74 year-old
Donald J Trump and 78 year-old Joseph R
Biden fought at the catch weight of 245
pounds Biden has had to drink for
insurers per day to make weight Bernie
Sanders was invited but there was not
enough pudding in the world to ensure
that he reached catch weight let's get
ready to stumble
oh and here we go Trump comes out
jabbing insulin Biden hits him with a
hard left and Trump is spinning dentures
Trump responds the clap to Biden's cheek
he clapped on and Biden clapped off
Biden's gonna feel that in his walk-in
bath tomorrow
Trump's out there looking a little bit
fuzzy out there as fuzzy as a tennis
balls on his Walker and now they're both
down on the mat they're both down on the
mat they are both napping oh and they're
back up again circling each other warily
looking for an opening and boom Trump
just pulled the old reverse mortgage on
Biden and Biden is down Biden is down
he's fallen and he can't get up he's
punching his life alert button oh my
goodness both of them now being carted
off in wheelchairs but to be honest both
of them were carted in in wheelchairs
but still so they would sound something
like that I mean wouldn't that be great
come on come on great for American
politics there's no way this goes wrong
are things incredibly stupid yes things
are incredibly stupid ladies things are
incredibly stupid well in other
stupid news it's time for Congress to
pass another crappy omnibus package so
this is a big omnibus package coming out
Congress is no longer capable they
actually just passing appropriations
bills here is the problem the the
Congress the House of Representatives
will go forward with appropriations
bills they will pass through the normal
appropriations process the way that
you're supposed to do budgets is you are
supposed to fund individual departments
and then you're supposed to send a bill
to the Senate and the Senate is supposed
to fund that individual Department and
the president signs it instead what has
happened because Mitch McConnell does
not have a governing majority in the in
the Senate he has 51 votes but they're
all fractious instead they just slap
everything together in a crap sandwich
with a bill that's two hundred and
twenty two two thousand two hundred and
thirty two pages long and then they give
people 48 hours to read it and say we
got a vote and they put a bunch of good
stuff in there and they put a bunch of
bad stuff in there so some of the good
stuff that is in there okay there is
there is some funding for the wall like
a very very very little bit of funding
for the wall there there you know
there's some things that are being
pushed by sort of the left wing of the
Republican Party there's increased
funding for the child care access means
parents in schools program which means
that parents will have access to
on-campus childcare and the sort of
thing if this is if this is your stuff
if this is the stuff that you like the
the funding is there for the military
this is what Speaker of the House Paul
Ryan has focused on he says that this is
the biggest increase in the military in
15 years the biggest pay raise for our
men and women in uniform in eight years
we need to rebuild our military so
there's an increase in funding for the
military it does a little bit of funding
for the wall it has a little bit of
funding for fighting opioid addiction
and it but and it does not in fact
enshrine daca so this is one of the
things Democrats are saying Democrats
are saying they're gonna vote against
the bill because the bill doesn't
provide full funding for the daca
program to allow people in the country
legally to remain here working legally
but that's because Democrats don't
actually want to deal on daca as I've
been saying for literally years at this
point on this show Democrats want to use
illegal immigration as a hot-button
issue when it comes to the elections but
they don't actually want to solve the
problems for illegal immigrants in fact
Paul Ryan went to the Democrats and he
offered them a really sweetheart deal he
offered them three years of funding for
the wall so 25 billion dollars over
three years for the wall and in exchange
three years of additional funding for
the daca program right we push off the a
con nobody'd get supported
Democrats turned that down flat okay and
they waited until the last minute to do
it and now they'll vote against the bill
saying that Republicans didn't give
enough so Democrats were offered what
they wanted on zakah and would have
brought them past the next presidential
election actually and they turned it
down anyway because they just want to
run on this issue here are some of the
conservative concerns with all this the
freedom clock is the house freedom
caucus has officially opposed the
Omnibus I've spoken to a lot of members
of the house freedom caucus spoken to
several senators who have opposed the
bill Senator Mike Lee in Utah is opposed
to the bill he says it's it's just
unconscionable that Mitch McConnell is
forcing through another one of these
omnibus packages that is essentially a
giant crab sandwich then nobody is going
to read here's what the freedom caucus
says in their statement they say the
policy proposals outlined in this 1.3
trillion dollar spending bill are not
consistent with what we told the
American people we would do when they
sent us to Washington many of the
policies in the bill are in fact the
opposite of what we promised in fact one
of the members of the freedom caucus was
saying to me yesterday that he was
tempted to call this the broken promises
Act of 2018 this bill barely provides
for border security yet continues to
allow federal dollars to flow to
sanctuary cities it also includes the
fix ni CS proposal without including
reciprocity for Americans with concealed
carry licenses something congressional
leadership promised would not happen it
continues to fully fund grants the co 2
Planned Parenthood it makes no changes
to reduce Obamacare's burdensome
regulations on America's families
doesn't get rid of Obamacare regulations
and on top of the massive price tag
leadership is forcing a vote on this
2230 two-page bill in under 36 hours
it's an insult to American taxpayers as
well as many rank-and-file
representatives who had no say in the
omnibus negotiations and the house
freedom caucus coming out
extraordinarily strong against all of
this now will it probably pass anyway
sure because the majority of Republicans
will vote for it and then there will be
a bunch of Democrats who vote for it
because the big omnibus package but
there's a procedural hurdle they have to
jump today it'll be interesting to see
whether they are able to do so because
in order for that procedural hurdle will
be jump every Democrat is gonna jump
against it it's possible that this is
this bill gets voted down and is brought
back for further changes so one of the
things that the freedom caucus talks
about there is the NIV fix an ICS bill
so what exactly is that Jacob solemn
over at Reason magazine says this he
says legislation aimed at improving
background checks for gun buyers may be
included in a must-pass spending bill
Congress is expected to approve tomorrow
or Friday the bill would encourage data
sharing with the FBI's National instant
criminal background check system is
faced a bunch of resistance for a
measure that has broad support some
the resistance is tactical because
Democrats want broader gun control but
there are also substantive concerns
about the bill raised by supporters of
gun rights who worried that it will help
block firearm sales to people who pose
no threat to others I'll explain why in
just a second first I want to say thank
you to our sponsors over at Lending Club
so listen we all need a helping hand
sometime whether it's unexpected repairs
or medical expenses or credit card debt
sometimes you just need a little bit of
money on relatively short notice
well Lending Club gives you access to
low rates on loans up to $40,000 for
almost any purpose right you need a home
loan because you need to hit you need to
make all those home improvements this is
better than going the bank it offers
lower rates and high interest credit
cards then you go to Lending Club com
here's how it works and you enter how
much money you need and you can see if
you are approved in minute and then you
pick the offer that is right for you and
the money can be in your accounts in
just a matter of days it is that simple
they've been working for over 10 years
to help millions of people with over
thirty 1 billion dollars in loans go to
Lending Club COMSOL Ashman you can check
your rate for free Lending Club comm
slash been and will not impact your
credit score as well as Lending Club
comm slash been Lending Club comm slash
been all the loans via Lending Club
these are top-notch products and you get
to choose right it's all about the
choice is up to you
Lending Club comm / been all loans made
by web bank member FDIC Equal Housing
lender check it out again if you're
looking for just that that swing loan
that you need for right now this is a
fantastic way to do it Lending Club com
/ Ben get your loans through Lending
Club again
Lending Club com / Ben lets them know
that we sent you as well and you can
check your credit for free and it
doesn't impact your credit rating you
can check the rates that you receive for
free so what exactly is the problem with
the fixed end ICS program that is
embedded in this bill well Senator
Cornyn from Texas introduced this last
November in response to the Sutherland
Springs shooting Cornyn's bill aims to
prevent the screw-ups that prevented the
sharing of information with the National
instant background check system ok they
would also encourage sharing of local
and state records but for example
senator Lee has due process objections
to the bill he argues that the
Department of Veterans Affairs wrongly
identifies veterans as mental defectives
which disqualifies them from gun
ownerships when they need help managing
their benefits right this was a serious
problem with an executive order that
Obama had tried to put out last year and
it was revoked by President Trump that
executive order was an attempt to
prohibit seniors who had other people do
their finances from owning weapon
well this sort of does the same thing
because the Department of Veterans
Affairs will say that veterans have
mental defective are mentally defective
if they need help managing their
benefits Lee says about 168 thousand
veterans have lost their second
Amendment rights as a result of that
particular policy Lee favors an
amendment requiring a judge to determine
a person's danger to himself or others
so nobody's against more transparency in
the National instant background check
system but the question is what standard
is going to be used to deny people a gun
and that standard does have to be
changed other conservative concerns with
this bill aside from the process aside
from the fact that these omnibus
packages stink that they are garbage and
again I think this is less on speaker
Ryan because the house has consistently
passed appropriations bills and it's
more on on Senator McConnell now listen
it's up to Ryan to pleased McConnell
right he could just tell McConnell
listen Bob you're on your own got it
right do the appropriations process do
what you need to do right and you do
this but he's not he's working with
McConnell bat-channel
this is one of the great intentions that
exists on the hill just was in
Washington DC yesterday my speech of
Georgetown was canceled by actual
snowflakes not like the students by like
actual snow I spend some time talking
with a bunch of congressional staffers
and a bunch of Congress people including
members of the freedom caucus and this
is the difficulty okay people like me
actually have a relatively easy job my
job is to get on the air every day and
to talk to you about the things that are
going on and to explain what I think is
right and wrong about these bills and to
analyze and to stump for better bills
when you're in Congress there's also a
tendency to try and get things done
right the government needs to be funded
we need to somehow we need to somehow
bridge the gap between what we want and
what we can get well sometimes that
makes things pretty awkward because
there are a lot of Republicans are going
to vote from an omnibus package number
one because they want to maintain their
seats and it's better to have a
Republican in that seat than the
Democrat and number two because they're
seriously concerned about things like
military spending so what's the easiest
way to do this the easiest way to do
this is slap together a crappy omnibus
package and then you say to your
constituents listen I didn't like a lot
of the stuff in there but I liked some
of the stuff in there and I needed to
vote for it because of that this is why
it's up to Mitch McConnell to do a
better job of keeping his members in
line now what's amazing is that a lot of
senators are afraid of Senate Majority
Leader McConnell a lot of senators are
afraid that he is sort of in de facto
control the National Senatorial
Committee for the Republicans the NR and
the NRC
that he is willing to remove money from
them or undercut them and so they are
willing to go along get along
with Senate Majority Leader McConnell
but the reality is that if they don't
stand up at a certain point and say to
McConnell listen we're not gonna vote
for these omnibus packages anymore we're
going to only vote for packages that we
like then you're never going to get
anything better the government is just
going to continue to grow so the
Republican Study Committee stayed up all
night last night to try and read through
this egregious bill and and some of the
stuff that they found in there truly is
truly is not great so let's start going
through it so here's what they say yeah
here's the statement from the Republican
from the Republican Study Committee they
say some conservatives will be concerned
that the bill would fund the federal
government at a level that exceeds the
BCA discretionary spending caps for
fiscal year 2018 prior to the passage of
the bipartisan Budget Act of 2018
particularly concerning is the increase
in non-defense discretionary spending
which exceeds the cap by sixty three
billion dollars in fiscal year spending
by sixty billion dollars the boost in
non-defense discretionary spending
represents the largest single year
increase in non-defense discretionary
since the BCA CAPTA stood be the
sequesteration caps were created
conservatives may believe this is a
reflection of the fact that Democrats
have been successful in handcuffing ndd
spending to fully funding at the
national defense together the omnibus is
increase in defense and non-defense
spending will increase the deficit by
143 billion dollars this goes to a point
that I've been making for a long time
Republicans are in the business of
cutting taxes they're not actually in
the business of cutting spending too
many Republicans don't care about
cutting spending see it's fiscally hard
to cut spending it is politically hard
to cut spending now you take a lot of
crap for cutting spending you never take
crap for increasing spending and this is
one of the problems here is that so many
folks are focused on being popular and
not enough focused on doing the right
thing especially in an off-year election
right in 2018 there's a fear that
Republicans gonna lose the house and
then what do you have then you have
Nancy Pelosi in charge of making these
laws so listen I have a lot of sympathy
for Republican staffers and Republican
House members trying to figure out what
to do here go back to the drawing board
give us something better this bill is
not up to the standards and what's the
point of you winning elections if you're
not gonna do anything with the power
once you finally have the power right it
continues to fund things like local
transit programs it funds the DC Opera
House it has large spending increases in
the agriculture appropriations division
which is idiotic it funds the National
Endowment for the Arts and Humanities
it funds the refugee and entrants
assistant programs it funds the Social
Security block grant program
it doesn't change Obamacare in any
significant way it does not include
dodd-frank rollback language it doesn't
include a provision prohibiting funding
for administrative expenses of an
Obamacare multi-state plan that provides
coverage for abortion it doesn't include
a provision to prevent to prevent
federal funding for ice enforcement to
provide for abortions the bill does not
contain the conscience Protection Act
the bill contains a treasury forfeiture
fund no explicit provision prohibition
on the gateway tunnel funding the bill
doesn't include a provision to prohibit
the EPA from implementing greenhouse gas
regulations in other words to garbage
program to fund the government so that
people don't actually have to do
anything and now again is there some
good stuff here yes I mean we do have to
fund defense ok defense has been just
slashed tremendously by the number of
but by by the Obama era cuts and that's
really you know quite disastrous that
the Obama did that in the first place we
have to ramp up our defense spending
again but Republicans are in charge and
it's report on Republicans had what they
what they pass here go back to the
drawing board make some changes I have a
feeling you can get at least something
better and get at least something better
because this is just not a thing right
this is just not a this is this is not
good enough for a Republican House to
pass okay meanwhile meanwhile Facebook
is finding itself in additional trouble
so Mark Zuckerberg has been on the hot
seat for quite a while here and he's
continuing to be on the hot seat but not
for a good reason
yeah I think there are lots of good
reasons for Mark Zuckerberg to be on the
hot seat I think it's a conservative the
discrimination against conservative news
outlets has been egregious over the past
several months and that's why you've
seen traffic drive traffic decline for
every conservative website you know like
all of them okay but the reason that
he's really getting flack is because the
left has decided that Mark Zuckerberg is
responsible for Hillary losing so let's
count all the people responsible for
Hillary losing according to the media
it's not Trump right Trump didn't win
the election he lost the people
responsible for Hillary losing are in
order James Comey the Russians the
conservative media and social media
right and so they've finally gotten to
the last time there was social media and
they're trying to encourage everybody on
social media to change the nature of
their algorithms in order to prevent
conservatives from disseminating
information so CNN is hot and bothered
about Facebook having allowed companies
to gather information from Facebook okay
which as I've said everyone does on
Facebook if you join farmville on
Facebook you are go if you play
farmville you are having your
information drawn for
Facebook every time you click on
anything on the internet somebody is
gathering that information in order to
drive an ad program to you this is how
people make money on the internet okay
but CNN grows a car Berg and ask can
people trust Facebook the answers of
course people can't trust Facebook they
never could trust Facebook and if you
thought that that Facebook was your
friend and that Facebook wasn't
attempting to market to you how do you
think they made their money it's
ridiculous Facebook has asked us to
share our data to share our lives on
this platform and has wanted us to be
transparent and people don't feel like
they've received that same amount of
transparency they're wondering what's
happening to their data can they trust
Facebook yeah so one of the most
important things that I think we need to
do here is make sure that we tell
everyone whose data was affected by one
of these rogue apps right and we're
gonna do that we're gonna build a tool
where anyone can go and see if their
data was a part of this but the 50
million people that were impacted they
will be able to tell if they were
impacted by this yeah we're gonna be
even conservative on that so you know we
may not have all the data in our system
today so anyone whose data might have
been okay this is such nonsense I mean
okay we want to know whose data was
affected everyone's okay on Facebook
because everyone is gathering
information for it from you all the time
on Facebook it's how Facebook makes
their money okay that's this is just
silly talk it's silly talk and
Zuckerberg pretending Oh we'll be fully
transparent Oh we'll finally reveal
everything that we know oh we're finally
going to show you the inside workings of
our car none of this is going to happen
none of this is going to happen
Zuckerberg is pandering by the way is
really egregious I mean he even says
that he would love to see regulations on
Facebook okay this is just nonsense
here's Zuckerberg saying that he's not
even sure that they shouldn't be
regulated given the stakes here why
shouldn't Facebook be regulated actually
I'm not sure we should be regulated what
the hell okay of course he's sure they
shouldn't be regulated why do you think
he's attempting to self-regulate right
now he doesn't want to be regulated
because he's afraid it will cut into his
bottom line so what's he doing he's
doing what Democrats want so they don't
regulate him okay this is outside
democratic pressure in order to ensure
that social media companies do a
Democrats want in a second I'm gonna
give you the update on what Zuckerberg
posted cuz he posted this long
ridiculous letter about about what's
been going on with the Cambridge
analytical situation I'm gonna read it
to you in just a second and analyze it
but first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at Zeile so March is
national
sleep Awareness Month I haven't been
getting enough sleep which is why over
this weekend I plan on using the Z lap
zeal is the leader in on-demand massage
they want you to know the best way to
get the most restorative sleep without a
new mattress or fancy equipment or
sleeping pills is a sleep massage
research shows it can help you sleep
better and treat insomnia all month long
seals 10,000 world-class massage
therapists are ready to help you sleep
better with your very own on-demand
sleep massage go to zeal comm or the Z
lap z ee l select the sleep massage
massage therapist gender time location
for your massage and as little as an
hour you're going to get a five-star
massage in your home they bring the
table they bring the sheets they bring
the the massage oils they bring the
scent and can't like they bring
everything they make the spa happen in
your house you're not waiting around for
a for a date to come up on the calendar
for the spa you're not paying inordinate
amounts of money that's what zeal is
it's great I mean I've gotten it as a
gift for many members of my family zeal
is offering you 20 bucks off your first
sleep massage with promo code been now
through March 31st go to zeal coms EEE L
calm and use promo code been to schedule
your sleep massage today again that zeal
calm promo promo code bed and use that
promo club n so you get 20 bucks off
your first sleep massage with with zeal
and again Aldermen species are just
tremendous they're all licensed it's
really terrific
okay so Mark Zuckerberg issues a letter
yesterday about the Cambridge analytical
situation and here's what he says quote
I want to share an update on the
Cambridge analytical situation including
the steps we've already taken and our
next steps to address this important
issue we have a responsibility to
protect your data and then he gives a
timeline of events races in 2007 we
launched the Facebook platform with the
vision that more apps should be social
your calendar should be able to show
your friends birthdays your maps should
show where your friends live in your
address book should show their pictures
to do this we enable people to log into
apps and share who their friends were
and some information about them in 2013
at Cambridge University researcher and
Alexandra Cogan created a personality
quiz app it was installed by about
300,000 people who shared their data as
well as some of their friends data given
the way our platform works at the time
this meant Cogan was able to access tens
of millions of their friends data in
2014 to prevent abusive apps we
announced that we were changing the
entire platform to dramatically limit
the data apps could access most
importantly apps like Cogan's who no
longer ask for data about a person's
friends unless their friends had also
authorized the app okay so here's what I
want to point out here okay what
happened in this timeline he goes from
2007 to 2014 he just skips over
everything else what huh what happened
between 2008 and 2012 we're like there's
some things that happened
like I seem to remember in 2012 for
example the Obama administration using
exactly the same strategy in order to
gather data on people everybody just
keeps right over that just cambridge
analytical it's doing terrible terrible
things listen so I think Cambridge
analytic may have been a little Shady
sure do I think they did anything
dramatically different as far as I am
aware then then the stuff that Obama was
doing am I supposed to be angry that
people gather data on Facebook this is
all nonsense it's all nonsense I mean
this is this is all crazy he says in the
next month we will show everyone a tool
at the top of your newsfeed with the
apps you've used in an easy way to
revoke those apps permission to your
data we already have a tool to do this
in your privacy settings now we will put
this tool at the top of your newsfeed to
make sure everyone sees it so I'm glad
they've used the news feed to get rid of
all the people you actually follow and
now they're going to insert a bunch of
crap that they want you to know about
but they're not going to allow you to
pick the people you choose to follow ok
Facebook is is increasingly a disastrous
medium and and Zuckerberg seems to have
lost control of his own pet project
which is an amazing it's an amazing
thing I mean there's a reason that the
stock is dropping okay so yesterday I
had the opportunity to sit down with
Paul Ryan and some of the folks who
helped us make this happen where the
folks my friends over at young America's
Foundation which is the exclusive home
of my college tours so we were in DC
this past week and even though the
city's shut down for the snow day yeah
helped us make sure that we were able to
sit down with speaker Ryan for a few
minutes to talk about some of the issues
Republicans are working on as well as
the future of the conservative movement
and here is what it sounds like well we
are here with Speaker of the House Paul
Ryan which is pretty awesome and we are
here in the in the ceremonial room
outside the speaker's office where
apparently they signed bills and have
heads of state which I'm sure you're
honored to be here with me you know that
there's a lot to talk about obviously
the elections are coming up and first
let me get your thoughts on on where you
think things are gonna head you know
it's a long ways away I feel good about
our chances midterm elections are hard
on the majority party midterm elections
for a president's first midterm on
average you lose like 32 seats we've got
a 24 seat majority so just clearly with
the headwind of history in front of us
that's not a good thing but I feel like
we're gonna have a tailwind of
accomplishments to get us into the
midterms we can get into the all the
agenda but we've done so many things
it's
a short period of time that will
actually made a positive difference in
people's lives and I think we're gonna
have a really good story to tell not to
mention the fact that our candidates our
members are battle-hardened they know
how to run tough tough races so I feel
very very good about where we are so I
want to start by talking about some of
those accomplishments and then I want to
get to sort of the the tactics that you
guys are gonna use in the in the
election campaign yeah so obviously you
know the the top of the list for
accomplishments is the tax bill and
Democrats losing their minds for the tax
bill did not look particularly good so
it's fair to point to Nancy Pelosi
saying that you've given the American
people crumbs and say that that's that's
wrong so how much do you think that'll
impact that's gonna be the gift that
keeps giving justice that just that
statement but every single Democrat
voted against this I really think they
did that
because they thought they were gonna
psych us into defeating ourselves it's
particularly in the Senate and when they
kept pushing this line they went so far
left so hard progressive that every
single Democrat voted against it they're
on the wrong side of history and they're
on the wrong side of results I've been
working on this issue a long time and
basically we have this is bigger than
1986 tax reform so this is the first
time in 31 years we've done tax reform
but it's much more profound than the tax
reform we did back then in 1986 because
this completely changes the way we tax
ourselves on an international
competitive basis and this will put such
a strong foundation of growth and
opportunity and free enterprise in
America more so than any kind of
economic reform in in my lifetime I'm
convinced of that and so they're on the
wrong side of history this takes a tax
system that was the worst in the
industrialized world and gives us a tax
system that we think is in the top three
of the industrial I'd worlds tax systems
that means more jobs in America more
opportunity in America businesses coming
back to America bringing capital back to
America expanding and that is a
phenomenally good thing it's gonna get
more careers better wages better
benefits more entrepreneurship and the
Democrats are against all of that well
one of the things that's really
difficult in the job that you have mr.
speaker viously that you are forced to
do pot I mean your job is to do policy
at the same time it seems to me that
elections are very little about policy
these days
and they seem to be much more about
different moral stances and maybe we
hope a battle of ideas right how do you
plan on tackling there because you know
we can talk about our policies being
great all day long if good policy one
Republicans would never lose but but the
problem is obviously that it
particularly polls among young people
they're really really egregiously bad I
mean 70 percent of my audience is under
the age of 35 and the polls even among
conservative youngsters from our
Republicans are not good how are you
gonna win the battle of ideas when when
you're so focused on talking policy and
is there a way to say it's always been
my issue
I've always strongly believed that
elections need to be about choices and
about ideas and that's why in 2016 I got
our House Republicans together to come
up with an agenda and to run on it we
called it the better way so that we
would have a game plan we would give the
country a very clear choice and that if
we won the election we would have earned
the right to put that agenda in place
where two-thirds of the way from doing
through doing that right now
and that gives us a good story to tell
which is here's what we said we would do
here's what we did this is what we did
in Wisconsin by the way in 2010 the
state legislature our governor it's a
model that I believe in that I saw work
there it's something we're trying to
apply here nationally and then we also
have to go with new ideas in the
election to continue this this reform
agenda to disrupt it now the point you
made I think is important about what
about young people the thing that
bothers me the most and I know you've
talked about this a bit these identity
politics I hate identity politics it's
wrong it's morally wrong but also it's
insidious and it's in its practice on
both sides our job is to reject identity
politics and try and replace it with
better ideas and idea and aspirational
politics I'm a jack camp acolyte I'm a
big believer in using our core founding
principles applying to the problems and
show that their solutions for everybody
and that to me is the kind of an agenda
and temperament we have to have going
into the 2018 elections and so I wanted
to ask you about that specifically not
in terms of you know efficiencies in
economics but about the moral
differences that you see between Lumpy's
I think these are that's the road issue
particularly for young people because
you know you and I are both big towns
actually you long before before I was
and and in a much more prominent way but
you're big on entitlement reform
form is obviously a difficult thing to
sell to a bunch of 17-year olds who
never think they will be 60 right you
know there's not a seventeen-year-old in
America who cares about their social
security because they're never going to
be of age to receive it and so you know
this when I speak to young people I try
to on a regular basis it seems to me
that what they really want to hear is
about this moral differentiation so in
your view moving below sort of the the
top of the iceberg in politics moving
below the water level what do you think
is the big distinction between right and
left and American politics that needs to
be elucidated yeah we believe in
equality of opportunity they believe in
equality of outcome equality of
opportunity means we want to make sure
that we use these guiding principles
that built this country liberty freedom
free enterprise self-determination
government by consents which gives you
an open economy which gives you freedom
which gives you the ability to chart
your life the way you want to and we
strive to promote equality of
opportunity so that the most people can
get the most opportunities possible and
nowhere else is that ever made more
clear than a free enterprise system and
then a freedom democratic capitalism
like we have like our system is a built
on natural rights what what the left
believes in and look you're asking it
conserving what the left believes in but
they believe in equality of outcome the
difference in the kind of size and role
of government you have between what
we're saying and what they're saying is
enormous having an equality of outcome
agenda means elites in Washington
unelected bureaucrats micromanage our
lives and are in everything we do in
such a way that they believe they have
to decide how our what the results of
our lives are that's very different
that's the sense of equality which is
they make things equal in the end and
the outcome of things that gives you a
stagnant society that gives you a
top-down society that gives you this is
I would come from Wisconsin which is the
birthplace the Progressive Party they
believe in all this early 20th century
progressivism and Hagel and Bismarck and
all these guys could basically think
that we're all rubes and doobs and we
don't know enough so we need to delegate
our power to these these these smart
bureaucrats that are insulated from
elections so they can harmonize and
micromanage our lives and that is an
equality of outcome philosophy
it's antithetical to our founding
philosophy and that at the end of the
day is the big difference here and so
the fights we have up here in many cases
not every one but in many cases are
fights of that origin
and I think that you know I've I've been
watching obviously your political ascent
for my entire life because but certainly
over the last day you know 15 years and
one of the things that I wish that you
had the opportunity to speak more about
that Steinem because it seems like
you're sucked more into speaking about
the efficiency on the day job yeah right
exactly exactly because we do need
thought leaders in the in the
conservative movement who are talking
specifically about the roots of the left
and talking specifically about the the
way that natural rights have been
overcome by a different regime of how
rights are thought about right the
difference in positive and negative
rights it right so when I go to I talk
to schools all the time young people I
always say look these are our rights
given to us pre government you didn't
have to believe in God to believe that
they come from God that they're pre
government so government can't take
those away from us that's us that's
where sovereign I don't even like the
idea of negative versus positive that's
more of a left construct but the idea of
government granted rights means we give
our power to the government I always say
the health care debate
everybody says health care czar right if
you buy into that premise then we're
saying we're giving our power to our
government to tell us how when where and
under what circumstances we get to
exercise that right we're giving the
government way too much power than we
should that's what the left is saying
when they say they want to grant us
these new rights the best thing that I
found when I talk to young crowds is if
we do not get entitlements under control
which we can with more choice and
competition and free enterprise and
choice if we don't get these things
under control we are gonna bankrupt the
next generation we've run the federal
government I round the numbers we've run
the federal government for the last 60
years by taking about 20 cents out of
every dollar made in America produced in
America to pay for the federal
government if we do nothing add no new
programs do nothing by the time my kids
are having kids we're gonna have to take
40 cents out of every single dollar made
in America to pay for this government at
that time before they even get on to
doing something else they want to do
with their government so we will
bankrupt the next generation I actually
had the CBO run numbers years ago and
what tax rates would have to be it goes
up as high as 88% for tax rates just to
pay for this government at that time so
I try to explain to people in dollars
and cents just what's going to
to them if the left gets their way they
produced this equality of outcome agenda
where we don't reform entitlements and
we stick with these kind of command and
control systems so I try to find a way
of of explaining in dollars and cents
what their future will look like from an
economic and tax standpoint and how
liberty and opportunity will be will be
crushed if we stay in this particular
path okay so I also before while have
the opportunity one they asked you about
sort of the legislature versus executive
balance because one of the things that
I've been critiquing for a long time in
the country and I was doing it under
Bush I was doing it under Obama I'm
doing it under the Trump administration
is the is the increasing power of the
executive branch is seemingly at the
expense of the legislative branch the
growing bureaucracy and the and the
feeling that the legislative branch over
the last century and a half really has
abdicated its duty to by kicking it over
to the bureaucracy a good example of
this being trade you know the president
obviously is is pushing a particular
agenda on trade this was not in the
purview of the executive branch
originally this is in the purview of the
legislative branch you know the Speaker
of the House what do you how do you hope
to if you do hope to reestablish the
balance originally we did some of we
except I wrote the trade promotion
Authority law which was it allow us to
go get trade agreements and we brought
some of that power back into the
legislative branch but not nearly as
much as we'd like so I can go into the
particulars of that but there's a couple
of things that we're trying to do here
that we've passed out of the house the
biggest complaint you'll hear from a
house Republican is the Senate
filibuster and getting things through
the Senate we have this thing called the
reins act which we think is sort of the
catch-all of reclaiming article one
which is 32 state legislators do this
you pass a big law it's vague and and
then the bureaucracy fills in the
details with its rules and regulations
and that just then happens and so you
end up having all these unelected
bureaucracies effectively writing the
law as we experience we think that's
wrong so what we're saying with this
reins Act which is you pass a law the
rules and regulations get published and
then those rules and regulations come
back to Congress for final vote and
approval or amendment before they go
into effect so that they're consented to
by the elected branch of government the
people who are elected to write the laws
before they go into effect and that
holds us accountable to so to that end
what we do is we try to in the bills we
pass since we can't get that
through the Senate yet we try to do it
on an individual basis on a bill by bill
basis and then I did something else we
had these lawyers called the Legislative
Council it's the Office of Legislative
Counsel it's their actual bill drafters
many said share the Ways and Means
Committee which is mostly tax laws and
health care law's tax laws have to be
written really tightly very very
prescriptive Lee and so I was worried we
were writing too big of a law we were
ending really vague laws and giving all
this discretion in the Yurok recei
except in tax laws so what I did was I
promoted the guy who was head of the tax
law writing department to run the entire
Legislative Council department to train
the other lawyers of the Legislative
Council how do you write law is really
prescriptively right so that we can
reduce the kind of open end of the
discretion we end up getting the
executive branch so I'm trying to change
sort of the culture of the way we
legislate here so that we're far more
detailed than prescriptive to not give
all this discretion to the executive
branch
I really appreciate you taking the time
and again you have one of the hardest
jobs and all I do not envy you but but I
appreciate that you're trying to make
philosophical arguments in a time when
it seems that a lot of people are
actually this is part of my day so thank
you okay so that was our sit-down with
Speaker of the House Paul Ryan we expect
to do a longer sit-down with him
sometime in the near future and then I
can ask him about things like today's
budget bill which is garbage and we can
talk a little bit more about what he
intends to do to stop the overreach of
the Senate which seems to only want to
pass these omnibus packages that are
that should not really be passed okay so
I'm going to talk a little bit about
other scandals brewing apparently stormy
Daniels is going to be on 60 minutes the
weather is getting a stormy and so we'll
talk about all of that but first you're
gonna have to go over to Daley wire and
subscribe for $9.99 a month you can get
a subscription to daily wire comm when
you do get the rest of my show live the
rest of Andrew Clavin Stroh live the
rest of Michael Molesey show live you
get to watch all of it on your screen
it's amazing and you also get to be part
of the mailbag which we'll be doing
tomorrow okay it's it's Thursday I've
completely lost track of time because
this week has been such a whirlwind but
we will be doing the mailbag tomorrow if
you wanna get your questions in and have
them read on air and answered on air
subscribe right now also if you want the
annual subscription you get this the
very greatest in all beverage vessels
the leftist cheers hot or cold tumbler
woohoo behold its majesty and you get
all
that when you pay $99.00 you're also we
do appreciate when you subscribe I get a
lot of letters from folks saying how can
you help the answer is you can subscribe
right if you subscribe it helps us bring
you the show it helps us bring you the
website
it helps us bring you the other shows
that we do and all the rest check it out
there if you want to listen later for
free go over to iTunes SoundCloud
YouTube stitcher or Google Play
all of those apps make sure that you
subscribe on all of them and download it
on all of them and leave us a comment on
all of them that's here that's your task
for today we are the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast in the
nation
[Music]
already so a quick roundup of other news
so meanwhile 60 minutes is now ready to
do its interview with stormy Daniels
according to the Daily Mail the head of
CBS News said Tuesday that a 60 Minutes
interview with stormy Daniels who is of
course the porn started the trumped is
on its way but that more journalistic
work needs to be done on the story David
Rhodes is the president over at CBS News
I've met him he's actually a reasonable
fellow I think he said in a conference
in Israel on Tuesday that the first time
CBS had confirmed that it interviewed
Daniels who has alleged an extramarital
affair with Trump before he became
president she passed a lie-detector it
was an of course he had an affair with
her of course
okay like okay I'm so tired of people
fussing around this issue oh she's lying
you're right she's lying as every other
porn star all the women are lying there
all along it's just not credible I'm
sorry Michael avenatti is a lawyer for
the actress whose real name is Stephanie
Clifford last week he tweeted a picture
of himself Clifford and Anderson Cooper
there no air date has yet been set for
the interview but they are preparing
Rhodes said he could not imagine what
the basis would be for any legal action
by Trump's team to prevent the interview
from airing this is one of the weird
things about the stormy Daniels story
Jonah Goldberg pointed this out a lot of
people saying well you know Trump denied
all the sorts of activity during the
campaign but he's not you know he's
denying that he had an affair with
stormy Daniels but then why would he be
paying stormy Daniels 130 thousand
dollars in order to shut her up like to
talk about an affair they didn't have
then he could sue her for libel so what
exactly would be the point of any of
this it doesn't make any sense at all so
all of this continues to continues to
roll out over over the Trump White House
none of it is obviously particularly
good for President Trump meanwhile
President Trump continues to fulminate
about Russia and Vladimir Putin he is
obviously very sensitive about comments
made about Russia a lot of people were
very critical with the president
including me and when he congratulated
the Russian President on his dictate his
dictatorial victory and in the new fake
elections over in Russia
he'd been bashed by some people
including Ben Sasse the senator from
Nebraska who I think says a lot of very
intelligent things sass said a couple of
things on the floor of the Senate the
other day he said number one Trump
obviously should not be praising Putin
and number two that material should not
be leaking from the White House which
obviously is true okay there's no way
that there should be material leaking
from the White
it says that people were telling Trump
not to and that it was written on a memo
in front of him do not congratulate
Putin there only a certain number of
people in that room
if Trump really wants to be sure he can
just fire everybody who's in the room
when he made the phone call or everybody
would seen that memo in any case here
was Ben Sasse saying what he said and
then Trump responding Vladimir Putin is
not a friend
Vladimir Putin is a despot the President
of the United States was wrong to
congratulate him and the White House
press secretary was wrong to dump to
duck a simple question about whether or
not Putin's re-election was free and
fair it was not the American people know
that the Russian people know that and
the world knows that and yesterday when
the White House refused to speak
directly and clearly about this matter
we were weakened as a nation and a
tyrant was strengthened sass went on to
talk about how and none of this stuff
should have been leaked from the White
House anyway which is of course true
Trump responded by ripping on everybody
else about his own comments about Putin
so here were some of his tweets on this
top he said I called President Putin of
Russia to congratulate him on his
election victory in past Obama calls
melosa ok that's true this is the truth
this is the fake news media is crazed
because they wanted me to excoriate him
they are wrong getting along with Russia
and others is a good thing not a bad
thing ok so far this is all somewhat
fair right they they never would have
called for Barack Obama to rip on Putin
in fact they were fine with Barack Obama
offering flexibility to Putin right
before a presidential election and then
handing over control of Syria in the
midst of a genocide to Vladimir Putin so
he's not wrong be critical of the media
but this is where he begins to go wrong
then he tweets this they can help solve
problems in North Korea Syria Ukraine
Isis Iran and even the coming arms race
Bush tried to get along but didn't have
the smarts quote/unquote smarts
nothing says says that you are a smart
person who can use the word smarts like
using scare quotes improperly Obama and
Clinton tried but didn't have the energy
or chemistry remember reset peace
through strength okay that's not a peace
through strength means they cannot help
us solve problems with North Korea they
have dealings with North Korea they
cannot help us solve problems in Syria
where they've been bolstering the Assad
regime in its genocide they certainly
cannot help solve problems in Ukraine
which they invaded they are not going to
help us with problems with Iran
considering that they are fans of Iran
and as far as the coming arm
races Vladimir Putin who's currently
testing long-range missiles again and
talking about how they're upgrading
their entire missile system to avoid
missile defense and Trump ripping on
Bush and saying he didn't have the
smarts is just yuck it's it I'm sorry
it's just it's classless and I love that
it's that he thinks here thing about
Trump Trump thinks that everything comes
down to personal relationship because in
essence President Trump is a Salesman so
he thinks that his relationship with
Putin is gonna go well because he's a
good salesman
okay Trump is a good salesman but that's
not how international relations work
good salesmanship does not mean that you
are better on the international stage
proper use of the the iron fist in the
velvet glove power and threat of force
and the use of those things right that
is the essence of diplomacy Trump is not
good at those things when he says peace
through strength Ronald Reagan's peace
through strength was that there would be
peace because they knew that if they
cross the line we'd bash them in the
head that's what peace through strength
meant Trump is saying nice things about
Putin for no reason then calling it
peace through strength that's not what
that is and it's foolish you're
president Trump to say that okay time
for a thing I like and then a thing I
hate and then we will be back here
tomorrow with mailbag so things I like
so this is well not for the kiddies it's
probably not for many of the adults
there's a show on Netflix called altered
carbon i-4 it is it is heavily new
defied okay it's like Game of Thrones
sound nudity lots of lots of boobies on
this particular show and it's not
particularly necessary I guess you could
make the argument that it's sort of
artistically necessary because the whole
point of the show is that there is a
future in which human beings have a have
their personality embedded in
essentially a computer chip and that
computer chip is in the base of their
skull and that computer chip can
actually be removed and implanted in
other bodies so you actually don't die
when your body dies they just take that
computer chip and they take all your
memories and everything they just stick
it into another body and you're good to
go and so this body substitution regime
is sort of the points of the sort of the
points of the series about five episodes
in it's sort of noir ish if you like the
Blade Runner 2049 it's blade is it's
it's that sort of feel it's this kind of
dark futuristic vision with neon colors
it looks a lot like that that movie
here's a little bit of the preview
your body is not who you are
you said it like a snake sheds of skin
we transfer the human consciousness
between bodies
to live fraternal life I believe I've
been down 215 years
do you are the property the Bancroft
industries you've been provided with
this body which came equipped with
military-grade Nurik em and combat
muscle memory
mr. Koh so it's an interesting series
two cool-looking series I've heard that
it gets kind of twisty near the end of
the first season so I'm looking forward
to that again it's it's heavily
pornified but the whole point here is
that it's actually not sexy so the the
fact that there is so much nudity
actually it's like Westworld it actually
makes it not particularly sexy
specifically because the the message of
the film is a message of the the series
is that your body is not all you are in
fact it's very little of who you are but
it is something addresses some
interesting philosophical questions so
worth watching if you can stand if you
can stand the an nc-17 rated of it okay
time for a quick thing that I hate
already so there are two quick things
that I hate first of all apparently
there's a student in the UK who is now
alleging that he was reprimanded by his
school for watching a video on a public
computer of me talking with Dave Rubin
hey here's what he said
I got reported by someone from watching
disturbing hateful content in university
premises and received an email from
faculty course officer who wanted to be
summoned for a student meeting and
apparently the student says that because
they they were watching this video of
Rubin and me and that they were that
they were threatened with suspension
from school this is certainly crazy but
it is unfortunately not all that
uncommon the left likes to bump into the
category of hate speech anyone that it
doesn't like this is why they're trying
to say the Jordan Peterson is
responsible for hate speech should've
said sam harris who's not even on the
right is responsible for a hate speech
all of it is stupid all of it is
nonsense and it's why hate speech
legislation like they have in Britain is
insanely dangerous because you can just
start banning viewpoints that you don't
like okay the other thing that I don't
like is Eleanor switz had a debate with
Jeffrey Toobin over on I believe CNN
about the Muller investigation and
Dershowitz has been making the Dersch as
we used to call him in Harvard Law
School has been making the case that I
think is a pretty solid case that the
that the investigation MoMA
investigation has exceeded its legal
boundaries and he's now taking in areas
where he was not originally designed to
go Jeffrey Toobin who's a former
gerschwitz student he says that
Dershowitz is now a show of the Trump
administration they go at it on CNN
here's what it looked like come about
that in every situation over the past
year you have been carrying water for
Donald Trump this is not who you used to
be and you are doing this over
over again in in situations that are
just obviously right with conflict of
interest and and it's it's just like
what's happened with you what conflict
of interest I attacked for is not you
I'm talking about not you your conflict
of interest this contact President Trump
for his banning of Muslims I attacked
President Trump for leaking material
about to Russia
I have attacked President Trump for many
many things I'm not carrying his water
I'm saying exactly the same thing I see
yours okay and Dershowitz is exactly
correct here of course you know you may
disagree through its analysis but it's
getting tiresome to watch people who
don't like Trump simply suggest that
anyone who defends Trump at any juncture
even if we've been very critical of
Trump and other junctures that those
people have now become shells for the
Trump administration this polarized
political environment is really gross
just because you defend Trump when he's
worth defending does not mean that you
like Trump overall or you think
everything that he's doing is right and
if you and just because you say that
Trump does something wrong doesn't mean
that you hate Trump overall you maced
elect Trump overall you know we should
be able to say what we think is right
and what we think is wrong I think tersh
which is done a pretty good job of that
all right we will be back here tomorrow
with the mailbag and look forward to
seeing you then i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alex and Garo audio is mixed
by Mike Carmina hair and makeup is by
Joshua Oliveira the Ben Shapiro show is
a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright floor publishing